Kerzengerade und majestätisch:
Zwölf Meter hoch und vier Meter breit ist
der Weihnachtsbaum vor Schloss Windsor,
der Hauptresidenz von Königin Elisabeth II.
Die Nordmanntanne stammt aus
der Heimatstadt ihres Ururgroßvaters.
Die Queen hat letztes Jahr in ihrer
Weihnachtsansprache davon berichtet,
dass der Weihnachtsbaum ja eigentlich
aus Coburg kommt,
als damals Albert die Queen Victoria
geheiratet hat.
Und das haben die Mitarbeiter
aufgenommen,
und dann kam die Idee:
Lasst uns doch ’n Brief
an die Queen schreiben und ihr
einen Weihnachtsbaum schenken.
Im November 2015 wurde die Idee
umgesetzt.
Die Stadt Coburg schrieb einen Brief
an die Queen
und bot einen Weihnachtsbaum aus
den Coburger Wäldern
samt Baumschmuck an.
Die Antwort aus dem Buckingham
Palace ließ nicht lange auf sich warten.
Die Queen sagte prompt:
„Yes, please.“
Zurück in Windsor:
Auch die Bürgermeisterin
des kleinen Ortes westlich von London
ist „amused“.
Es ist eine große Ehre,
so etwas aus Deutschland
für Großbritannien zu bekommen,
vor allem in unserer Stadt Windsor.
Wir fühlen uns sehr privilegiert,
den Baum hier zu haben,
vor allem auch mit all der Dekoration.
Er sieht toll aus.
Und so fing alles an:
Königin Victoria ehelichte Albert
von Sachsen-Coburg und Gotha.
Der Deutsche brachte 1848 den ersten
Weihnachtsbaum nach England.
So wurde der Baum Teil der
britischen Weihnachtstradition.
Victoria und Albert sind die
Ururgroßeltern von Königin Elizabeth II.
Geboren wurde Prinzgemahl Albert hier,
auf Schloss Rosenau bei Coburg
im Jahre 1819.
Noch heute lebt ein Teil der Familie
in dieser Gegend,
so auch Erbprinz Hubertus.
Er hat den Weihnachtsbaum für
die Queen gespendet.
Uns wurde gesagt, zwischen zehn
und circa zwölf Meter.
Die Höhe war
auch nicht so sehr das Thema.
Es war eher das Thema die Breite.
Er durfte maximal im Durchmesser
vier Meter haben.
Da an dem Standort,
wo er aufgestellt wird,
am Schloss Windsor
direkt hinter der Queen-Victoria-Statue,
auch ein „Changing of the Guards“
durchgeführt wird
und dort natürlich die Wachen noch
durchkommen müssen,
ohne den Baum zu berühren.
Das war eine gewisse
Herausforderung,
einen Baum zu finden,
der eben diese Höhe hat,
aber maximal die Breite.
Wir haben’s geschafft,
haben einen ganz tollen, gerade
gewachsenen Baum gefunden
und sind sehr froh darüber.
Die rund 30 Jahre alte Nordmanntanne
wird im Coburger Wald gefällt
und offiziell verabschiedet.
Von der bayerischen Provinz startet
eine rund 1000 Kilometer lange Reise
über den Ärmelkanal
nach Großbritannien.
Ein paar Tage später:
Die Tanne hat die Fahrt gut überstanden
und thront nun vor
dem Schloss Windsor.
Die Residenz der britischen Monarchen
ist das größte und älteste
durchgängig bewohnte Schloss der Welt
und Hauptwohnsitz der Queen.
Dass der Weihnachtsbaum
dieses Jahr aus Coburg kommt,
ist kein Zufall.
Es wird in Coburg der zweihundertste
Geburtstag von Prinz Albert gefeiert
mit jetzt schon in Planung
befindlichen Veranstaltungen,
und da haben wir einen großen Wunsch,
ein großes Ziel,
einen großen
Traum vielleicht sogar:
Wenn es uns gelingt, dann in zwei Jahren
jemanden von der königlichen Familie
in Coburg begrüßen zu dürfen,
dann war das ein richtig voller Erfolg.
Damit die Bescherung perfekt ist,
wird der Weihnachtsbaum traditionell
geschmückt –
mit rund 2000 Weihnachtskugeln
aus Lauscha.
Die deutsche Stadt in der Nähe von
Coburg
ist weltberühmt für ihren Glasschmuck.
Mehr als ein halbes Jahr Arbeit steckt
in dieser Dekoration.
Etwas ganz Besonderes ist es,
weil die Kugeln handgemacht sind.
Wir haben diese Kugeln auch aus über
30 Jahre alten Glasröhren hergestellt,
die früher in der Nähe von Lauscha
hergestellt worden sind.
Zwei Tage lang dauert es,
bis alle Kugeln und Kerzen am Baum
windfest angebracht sind.
Der Weihnachtsbaum der Queen
ist der neue Star von Windsor
und zieht alle Blicke auf sich.
Es ist herrlich vor dem Schloss.
Es ist wunderschön.
Ich mag den Baum.
Er ist groß und gut proportioniert.
Einfach großartig!
Es ist sehr schön, es ist magisch.
Bis Anfang Januar kann diese
Schönheit
noch in Windsor bewundert werden.